and I I think the era of the Rockstar
game designer is kind of dying and it's
kind of sad you know because I think you
know uh the the people the powers that
be that have the money and own and
control these Studios they don't want
there to be one person seen as them
because it very much is a team effort
yeah you know so whatever you see an
update for valorent or Apex Legends or
fortnite it's signed by the team right
you know Donald mustard is the main
creative behind fortnite but not a lot
of people know that right and he was the
one you know responsible for Infinity
Blade for shadow complex
um and he's he's uh he's a creative
genius but he's also incredibly
charismatic the kind of guy that can
stand in front of a room and sell you on
an idea
I thought you was epic like it was it
was a time where I just only thought
like you were that right there I mean
that was that was my plan
was well executed because I saw a
Lamborghini
here we go here we go you know what